my god
i am loving the show so much i'm so in
and your characters they're they're very
complex people
um to say the least you try not to say
something horrible um well there is a
lack of you know uh pure intentions
um but does that make for juicier roles
to play and characters to watch as an
audience
yeah i think it's i think so it's always
better to play people who behave badly i
think because and probably in life it's
better to no no i'm not going to say
that
but it's nice it's nice to step outside
of kind of behaving yourself and say the
things you want to say and do the things
you want to do and not really care about
the consequences and because they're
such awful
people it's kind of nice to watch the
train wreck
yes and and yet i feel like i've been in
that relationship
i didn't have a little ptsd watching it
i kid you not because i i i was who was
it drew
i'll never say it i'll never tell but i
i was in a relationship with someone
where
overnight uh i thought i was with one
person and all of a sudden they were not
that person anymore
and i that happened we have a
relationship right
no but you are with someone who i'm also
in love with jennifer connelly as her
wife
oh my god i love her so much
um
i mean
have you always been in love with her
did you see her in labyrinth is that
true yes i did well yes i did everybody
saw her in labyrinth and was that the
moment
yes but i don't think i was alone in
that you know i think every other 10
year old boy uh had a similar sort of
awakening as it were that's right
funny enough i think story makes me
sound like a weird stalker
and then 20 years later having watched
her comings and goings
i also loved her i just i everything and
she's in the new top gun movie which
i've seen the trailer for 15 times
the movie's fantastic
i've seen it did she enjoy working with
tom cruise she did she did i mean i
think she was a little terrifying
because he would say things like uh
so we're going to shoot this and i'm
going to fly the plane and you're
getting in the plane and she's like well
you know so i think that was a little
terrifying and what is a great pilot
what about literally the motorcycle like
i see them on a motorcycle and i can
always tell that he is not tethered to
anything he is riding that beast into
the sunset with
no blanks given
what was i mean that must have been
exciting
terrifying and exciting but like
to let tom cruise just take the wheel
yeah i i think it's sort of hard to stay
looking glamorous uh 80 miles an hour
with wind in your eyes you know well you
look like you're crying yes because it's
80 miles an hour and there's wind in my
eyes according to the trailer she pulls
it off she does
um and
you are vision
i am i mean
yes
catherine han came on the show i tried
everything i could to poke and prod and
goat and
like reverse psychology and gaslight to
get any information out of her
whatsoever
[Laughter]
i mean it ends on a cliffhanger and is
it true like marvel doesn't like
cliffhangers there's such a purpose
behind that what's going to happen with
vision
well drew uh
i don't know i actually don't know but i
do know that you're right that kevin
feige doesn't like loose ends and i do
fly away at the end so i'm hoping that
there will be a future for vision if
only that i can keep my kids in private
school
according to that performance um
you will definitely be back because you
were so wonderful in that role you're
you're strong you're romantic you made
all of us women weaken the knees like
seriously when you're like yes my love
we're all like
why is no man saying that to me oh my
god it's so great well i had a team of
women writers
well that doesn't hurt but you still
have to be the one like with that
chemistry and pulling it off at the end
of the day so well done all of you guys
thank you very much
[Music]
you